we live in a world in which we are
saturated with dopamine and we live in a
culture which encourages us to pursue it
but the ultimate end result of pursuing
dopamine is to feel worse than when you
started
so dopamine is a neurotransmitter which
means that it is the molecule that
allows the electrical signal from the
presynaptic neuron to be communicated to
the postsynaptic neuron because there's
a little gap called the synapse between
those two neurons so neurotransmitters
allow fine tuning of those electrical
signals and dopamine is the most
important neurotransmitter involved in
motivation and reward
and the fundamental difference between
things that are addictive and those that
aren't is that things that are addictive
release a lot more dopamine
so we have dopamine firing in our brain
that occurs at a tonic baseline
and when we do something that's
rewarding or pleasurable we get a little
rise in dopamine levels or a spike
so for example chocolate increases
dopamine levels about 50 percent above
baseline
sex is about 100 percent nicotine is
about 150 percent and things like
methamphetamines are a thousand percent
partially because of their their
specific
mechanism
but the the fundamental way that i
explain to patients and medical students
and now in my book um about the
neuroscience of addiction so that they
can really understand what's happening
in the brain
is i say that
really you have to imagine that in your
brain there's a balance like a
teeter-totter and a playground when we
experience pleasure the balance tips one
way when we experience pain it tips the
other
but one of the fundamental rules
governing that balance is that it wants
to remain level
so with any deviation from neutrality
the brain will work very hard to restore
a level balance or what's called
homeostasis
so for example if i do something
pleasurable like eat a piece of
chocolate i get a little tip to the side
of pleasure a little release of dopamine
but no sooner that has that happened
then my brain adapts to that phenomenon
by down regulating my own dopamine
receptors down regulating my own
dopamine transmission and i imagine that
is these little gremlins hopping on the
pain side of the balance to bring it
level again
but the thing about the gremlins is they
like it on the balance so they stay on
until the balance is tipped an equal and
opposite amount to the side of pain and
that's called the opponent process
reaction the hangover the come down the
act after effect
now and in my case that's that's that
moment of wanting another piece of
chocolate
if i wait long enough the gremlin hot
hops off and balance is restored but if
i continue to consume chocolate in ever
larger amounts to overcome the tolerance
or the number of gremlins on the pain
side then i end up with enough gremlins
on the pain side of my balance to fill
this whole room and i'm essentially in a
dopamine deficit state with a balance
tilted to the side of pain now i have to
keep using not to feel good but just to
feel normal and when i stop using
my balance tips hard to the side of pain
i'm irritable i'm depressed i'm anxious
i can't sleep those are the universal
symptoms of withdrawal from any
addictive substance and that can last
a long time yeah
i think it brings up an important kind
of broader
point about
culture in general and this idea that we
live
in a situation in which
we are
um there's this there's this asymmetry
in terms of how we approach our lives
with respect to pleasure and pain and we
organize our lives
completely around the pursuit of
pleasure and the avoidance of pain
but as you kind of astutely put in the
book the more that we pursue that
ultimately the more pain that we reap
because these systems require
a level of homeostasis that we're
constantly trying to avoid so
we're just
delaying the inevitable onslaught of
pain that that you know we so fear
yes absolutely we live in a world
in which we are saturated with dopamine
and we live in a culture which
encourages us to pursue it but the
ultimate end result of pursuing dopamine
is to feel worse than when you started
and and this is really the central
message
people are
more depressed more anxious more
suicidal and more addicted than they
were 30 years ago and i contend that one
of the main reasons is because of this
relentless pursuit of pleasure that
essentially adjusts the dopamine levels
changes the hedonic or seizure or
pleasure set point to make people and
hedonic meaning without joy yeah and and
you can kind of calibrate this in
lockstep with how
we've progressed from
uh a world of scarcity into a world of
over over abundance right and so
these addictive behaviors and substance
substances are ubiquitous it used to
just be you know hard drugs and and
alcohol and cigarettes etc but now it's
literally everything from
you know the billboards and the
advertisements and the marketing
messages crafted by madison avenue to of
course the devices that we all carry
around with us that are specifically
designed to
lure us into this you know dopamine
induced state and
the food system that's specifically
designing foods with the right
proportion of salt sugar and fat to make
it impossible to just eat one potato
chip
yes exactly i mean addiction can happen
now in every realm of life it's almost
impossible to escape it and the three
factors that make anything more
addictive are quantity potency and
novelty
and what our capitalist technologically
innovative world has created is an
infinite quantity incredible potency and
endless novelty and variety
and ubiquitous availability yes right
it's unavoidable yes right now and now
it's 24 7 and it's digital and it's
right to your doorstep exactly right
everything's delivered as well yes right
including all the substances
[Music]
you